[Music]
foreign
everybody just eight weeks ago we had
the mini budget that was unceremoniously
unpicked within days today the man who
did that will set out his plan for how
to plug the financial black hole the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt is expected to
raise taxes cutting public spending and
scale back energy support for households
Mr Hunt will say difficult decisions are
necessary to keep mortgage rates low and
Tackle inflation which has soared to a
41-year high let's take a look through
what's expected today while the
chancellor will be trying to fill a
black hole of around 54 billion pounds
in government finances it's understood
that will involve 30 billion in spending
cuts but the NHS is expected to get more
money with the education budget also
likely to be protected we're told the
other 24 billion will come from tax
Rises mainly targeting the richest
though the chancellor admitted at the
weekend that everyone will be paying
more tax
and the cap on the amount a typical
household pays in energy bills will rise
to 3 000 pounds from next April Sky News
understands additional payments will be
given to pensioners and low-income
households our Deputy political editor
that's Sam coats of course looks at How
Deeply the impact of today's
announcement will be felt
it was a lot I know so we're going to
recap their parents knew the impact of
rising prices now these children are
having to learn too
at copthull school in Barnet 40 of the
students are eligible for free School
meals
it's part of an education system and a
community that's feeling the strain
these teenagers are already well aware
of that struggle people just look at us
like we're children they don't
understand that we have an understanding
of what's going on around us it has
impacted us as students like majorly
it's quite aggravating because our
generation isn't seen as
like a strong generation we're kind of
overlooked
more or less a decade of spending
squeezes has already meant years of
difficult decisions and meager pay Rises
they see the teacher says there's no
more left to cut it's completely
unsustainable so we're already in a
tight situation but moving forward
there's going to have to be very
creative decisions on what we do next
that's likely to mean larger class sizes
Cuts in some curriculum areas six seven
years more of squeeze how does it
actually feel
it makes me question whether I will be
able to maintain that sort of resilience
warnings like that are why School
budgets will Dodge the worst of the
squeeze to come but plenty of pain
elsewhere so much of the focus of Jeremy
Hunt's Autumn statement will be on the
challenging tax rise is to fill the
black hole
but arguably the bigger story here will
be the announcement of years more
squeeze on public spending lasting most
of the rest of this decade local
councils Social Services investment in
transport all facing more pain off the
back of all the austerity of the last
decade
this is the third big economic statement
this year by the fourth Chancellor of
2022 will this one set a course we stick
with Sam coat Sky News
thrilled to have capri with us uh this
morning new addition to our team good
morning great to see you what are we
expecting we heard a little bit there
from Sam yeah so the chancellor is going
to be administering pretty painful
medicine today and it's come back to
ills higher inflation and as a result of
that higher interest rates they've been
wreaking havoc on the economy
um very few people will have failed to
notice that
um and the obr will be laying all of
this bear today that's the office for
Budget responsibility it's the UK's
fiscal Watchdog it will be showing how
far these have led to a deterioration in
the Public Finance so they're basically
the people that Mark is homework aren't
they and they were set up after the
financial crisis because the treasury
was criticized for essentially putting
out flattering forecasts okay so it's
about providing an independent set of
forecasts and the government sets its
policy decisions against those forecasts
so we think that obr today is going to
say that in order for the government to
meet its fiscal Target Jeremy Hunt will
tell us what that is but we think that
it's for debt to be falling as a
proportion of GDP within five years that
it will need to find 55 billion pounds
of savings that means tax Rises and it
means public spending cuts
um okay I we saw a budget didn't we a
mini budget at the end of September that
was a disaster and the markets let us
know about that very quickly
I'm guessing they'll react quite quickly
as well one way or the other to to this
one from our president Chancellor yeah
and and one of the reasons that we've
got these fiscal targets one of the
reasons that Jeremy Hunt is doing this
is because he's trying to reassure the
markets he's trying to reassure them
that the UK is a credible place for
investors to invest essentially and we
saw after that disastrous mini budget
what happens when investors lose
confidence in the UK economy government
borrowing costs they went through the
roof and there's a real risk here but
it's all about striking a balance
because we're already in recession
probably and household incomes are being
massively squeezed
some are arguing that Jeremy Hunt risks
going too far in an effort to
overcompensate a time when it's already
pretty painful for us but if he doesn't
do any of this then markets may not
trust him you may not believe that he's
actually going to do the things that he
says he's going to do and that will lead
us into a whole new set of problems oh I
understand thanks very much indeed for
explaining that to us good we thank you
with us throughout the morning here on
the program Dan's joining us as well hi
Dan
um good morning to you you're talking to
people who are I'm sure anxious about
what the chancellor might be saying
about half past 11.
yeah up and down the country there are
businesses and there are members of the
public all of us who will be watching
watching the chancellor to see how they
are going to be impacted we are at the
Windmill Hill City farm right in the
center of Bristol as you can see there's
a cafe there's a farm shop they're just
preparing now to open but it's a
business that's had to diversify over
the last few years they also have a
children's nursery they do a lot of
school trips a lot of Outreach work and
they like all businesses have been
impacted by the cost of living crisis
over the last year or so we can have a
chat to the chief executive Steve Sayers
of windmill Hill City farm thanks for
letting us in early as you're setting up
here just before we come on to what you
want from Jeremy Hunt in this Autumn
statement tell us how you're impacted
because I hear that your energy costs
alone have tripled yeah we we're
expecting the energy bills have gone by
about three times we were paying twenty
thousand pounds two years ago and it's
now going to be 56 58 000 this year so
it's pretty steep but beyond that really
the cost of staff is the big thing for
us you know we're a real living wage
employer we want to do well by our staff
and that rate has gone up by 10 this
year we've seen inflation yesterday at
that 40-year high 11.1 percent how does
that away from the staff and obviously
having to pay them a living wage that
impacts your businesses in terms of the
things in this Cafe absolutely we are
seeing prices in the cafe get up every
single day and of course there's a lag
how quickly you can put prices up to
customers and what they will actually
come in and spend their money on so
we've seen the basket price drop so you
know 12 months ago eight pound was a
typical spend in the cafe it's down to
about six pound fifty people share a
piece of cake rather than having one
each very quickly Steve what are you
looking for from the chancellor what do
you want what's your top demand really
some investment so one into early years
as a sector that has been desperately
underfunded for years and then two into
Community buildings in Energy Efficiency
so we can improve the way the building
operates okay Steve I'll let you carry
on setting up the cafe opens in a couple
of hours investment is what Steve wants
at this business I don't know whether
that's going to be the top line of the
chances a statement spending cuts tax
Rises May more be the thing that we're
going to hear about today we'll be
speaking to people in the cafe parents
dropping off their kids at the nursery
in the next hour or so to get a full
spectrum of how people are feeling and
what they want from Jeremy Hunt later
this morning
okay Dan thanks and from 11 we'll have a
special program ahead of the Autumn
statement right here on Sky News the
chancellor expected to address the
commons around about 11 30. that special
program from 11.
quick look at the papers for you well
the Metro headline here we go grin and
bear it that's ahead of Jeremy Hunt's
Autumn's statement where he will raise
taxes and cut spending
uh the guardian reporting that Jeremy
Hunt May lift the price cap on energy
bills affecting millions of households
the Mirror covers a speech by the head
of MI5 yesterday saying there have been
at least 10 plots by Iran to kidnap or
murder Brits on UK soil in the last year
talking about that in more detail with
the Britain's former top spy
on the show and the Daily Mail focusing
on the rationing of eggs and that's no
yolk in supermarkets amid the bird flu
outbreak and the war in Ukraine
I know I think I'm funny nobody else
does still to come on the program for
you we'll speak to Britain's former top
Spicer said uh that's Sir John Sawyers
as the head of MI5 reveals new details
about attempts by around to Target
individuals in the UK
[Music]
past seven uh joined by former Boris
Johnson advisor Alex Crowley to talk
about the investigation into Dominic
Robb's conduct amid bullying allegations
[Music]
and just before eight the lib Dems
treasury spokesperson Sarah Olney will
be here ahead of the Chancellor's Autumn
statement
and the shadow Chief secretary to the
treasury that's Pat McFadden he's also
going to be with us after eight
a new study shows new mums in Britain
are three times as likely to die than
those in Norway or Denmark
how can that be shimana is standing by
for us this morning at the Department of
Health hi shiman good morning to you
this goodness mayor tell us more about
these figures
yeah they are concerning figures aren't
they what this research was carried out
by International researchers and they
looked at mortality in maternity rates
across eight different European
countries and it found that in the UK it
had the second highest mortality rate
with one in ten thousand mothers dying
within six weeks of given birth and it
only came second slightly less than
Slovakia in that study so it found that
across all nations the mothers were at
higher risk if they were younger mothers
or older than this and it found that the
main causes the heart disease and
suicide which is really concerning
considering that the latter with the
right mental health support could
potentially be avoided so it found that
in the UK as well that blood clots were
also a leading cause when it came to new
mothers as well and this data comes
after data that was published at the
start of November by Embrace I'm Embrace
or an organization which tracks healthy
mothers and their babies and that found
that they're being an increase of nearly
20 percent of maternal mortality cases
and they found also that women living in
the most deprived areas were more than
twice as likely to die than those living
in the most affluent parts of the UK now
a Department of Health spokesperson has
said that they have already invested
around
127 million pounds into the maternity
system to boost the workforce and to
improve care but if there's one thing
that we know is that it's not really
something that you can just throw money
at there's going to be a lot of work
needed to try and improve these cases
because we're already hearing today
aren't we from the national report by
the National Audit office that has found
that the NHS is already under
considerable pressure and that word
inflation Has Come Around again as they
said that the money that has been put
into trying to clear up some of these
NHS backlogs has been chipped Away by
the rising um inflation
okay for now thank you
National Audit office excuse me has
warned the nhs's plan to cut long
weights for treatment by 2025 excuse me
there we go is it serious risk because
funding hasn't kept pace with inflation
uh the elective care waiting list has
continued to increase reaching 7 million
patients in August of 2022. this
includes 387
000 patients who've already waited
longer than a year for treatment
compared with just 1600 in February of
2020 found cancer referrals have
increased but life-saving treatment is
being delayed in the year to the end of
August only 62 percent of patients
started cancer treatment within 62 days
compared with 78 in the previous year
there are definitely things the NHS can
do to improve the situation it can
improve its own Central management of
the recovery plan it can look carefully
at all of the ways it can fill staff and
gaps this is very important there's
seventy and a half thousand Staffing
gaps in the NHS earlier this year and
that was higher than before the pandemic
and it can also look at what it can do
to improve staff morale and well-being
so that people are more willing to do
overtime and extra shifts again
I want to tell you about the Chinese
president Xi Jinping his chest star is
Justin Trudeau at the G20 Summit
yesterday in Bali accusing the Canadian
Prime Minister of leaking details of
their meeting to the media take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's create the conditions first
um
eek let's speak to Helen Anna should we
uh he wasn't very happy was he Helen and
good morning
good morning no not very happy at all
and it's worth saying this is really
highly unusual uh to see something like
this diplomatically more broadly but
certainly for president XI of China it's
hard to overstate just how carefully
managed how closely choreographed all of
his public appearances are and in that
clip as you can see he's really quite
agitated and really quite angry worth
saying I think this almost certainly
will not have happened by accident
because as I say it's very very unusual
almost unheard of for things to be done
sort of off the cuff for president XI
but I think it is uh you know quite
embarrassing for president Trudeau worth
saying that the meeting between the two
men was actually not a scheduled part of
each of their schedules um it happened
quite a brief reasonably spontaneous
meeting apparently as part of another
event so there is a chance that the
Chinese anger about this was perhaps
because they didn't get a chance to
prepare their response Canadian media
did write up quoting Mr Trudeau's office
afterwards that they had discussed North
Korea and Ukraine and Chinese
interference in Canada so perhaps that's
part of the explanation but a
fascinating Insight I think and a rare
one into how president XI conducts his
diplomacy in that quite assertive way
okay um just while I've got you talk to
me about what's going on in Myanmar
um I remember a British Diplomat
um being taken into custody am I right
in saying that she's been released today
yeah that's right in Myanmar it appears
that 6 000 prisoners are set to be
released by the military Hunter there
they say it's to Mark myanmar's national
day and amongst that 6 000 our four
foreigners and one of those a lady Vicki
Bowman she's actually the former British
ambassador to Myanmar she was Ambassador
there between 20 2002 and 2006 and she's
been running a not-for-profit there ever
since and she was arrested alongside her
husband who's a Myanmar National an
artist and a human rights campaigner in
the summer the charges they were charged
with at the time was about breaking
immigration laws about them not having
properly registered where they live but
not much understanding there and around
the globe was actually was more
politically motivated than that so she's
been detained since August there and
she's been released as I said alongside
a Japanese national an American and an
Australian
um as well Myanmar obviously has been
under the rolling Hunter after a
military Hunter after a coup that took
place there in February last year and
there's been a long period of turmoil
lots of protests violently put down at
times over 2 000 people expected to have
died are predicted to have died and in
that time they're so interesting indeed
that this British ex-dipument has been
released
okay for now thank you
um which I'm telling you there about
Vicki Bowman haven't we who's a British
Diplomat who are living in Myanmar has
now been released meantime a man in the
U.S in the state of Wisconsin actually
he's been sentenced to 762 years in
prison for driving into a Christmas
parade last year six people including an
eight-year-old boy were killed when
Daryl Brooks Jr drove his SUV into the
parade in Milwaukee after getting into a
fight with his ex-girlfriend the judge
became emotional when delivering the
ruling
it's hard not to think about what I
watched
and not have this reaction
those are images that frankly kept me up
at night
that I saw over and over
and over
also making use a 14 year old has died
following a suspected stabbing in your
Castle Gordon Gorge was taken to
hospital following an altercation in the
elswick area last Wednesday but sadly
died six days after the incident local
police had made 14 arrests as part of
their ongoing investigation
foreign
allies have clashed with Russia at the
U.N security Council over responsibility
for a deadly missile strike in Poland
while we still don't know all the facts
we do know one thing
this tragedy would never have happened
but for Russia's needless invasion of
Ukraine and its recent missile assaults
against Ukraine's civilian
infrastructure
it was Ukrainian missiles that crossed
into polish territory launched by
Ukrainian air defense systems
that means that this is not just an
intentional attempt of disinformation
but a conscious attempt to involve NATO
which is in conducting a proxy war with
Russia in Ukraine to involve it into
direct conflict with our country we
should be clear
that this is a tragedy that indisputably
stems from Russia's illegal and
unjustified invasion
and it's inhumane assault on civilians
across Ukraine
what a mockery of Peace efforts that
terrorists
are still at the table on an equal
footing with 14 members of the security
Council
one day after the Grievous attack on
Ukraine's critical infrastructure
while NATO's Chief and Poland's
president has said there's no indication
it was a deliberate attack and was
likely a rocket launch by Ukraine
fending off Russian missiles and drones
in his nightly address the President
says his country is being transparent
one of the main issues that the U.N
security Council is the situation in
Poland clarifying all the circumstances
of how Russian aggression across the
Polish border
the Ukrainian position is very
transparent we strive to establish all
the details every fact
well Siobhan's standing by four is now
on the Polish Ukraine border hello to
you uh Siobhan looks like it was a
terrible accident
yes if you have a look behind me just on
the ridge of that Hill there is where
this investigation is focusing that's
one of the Grain Stores where this
Missile hit killing two people and it
was such a tense moment when that
happened earlier this week real concerns
that this possibly had been fired by
Russia the first time that a missile has
hit Poland since the war in Ukraine
broke out but these provisional findings
from the polish from NATO from the U.S
suggesting actually this wasn't fired
from Russia in fact it was linked to
Ukrainian air defenses but interestingly
this isn't an open and shut conversation
you heard there president zielinski is
challenging that intelligence at the
moment he's insisting this wasn't
Ukraine's missile this was not Ukraine's
missile strike and he's asking for
access to the investigation that's going
on here now that's being run by the US
and Poland we're not sure if that access
is going to be granted but it's a real
reminder here that this war which the
Ukraine have been living through for
months is so close to everyone and it's
so easy for it to spill over
okay for now thank you
see the weather starting to change there
on the Ukraine Poland border and that is
very much going to impact on the war
between Russia and Ukraine talking about
that
um to come later in the program uh
meantime let's tell you about the
Brentford Striker Ivan Tony who missed
out on England's World Cup squad
um he's been charged with breaching fa
betting rules
232 times let's get more now should we
from Rob who is in Doha for us this
morning
um hello to you rob we were expecting
him to be in the squad weren't we now I
think we'd probably know why he wasn't
yeah they've been quite a clamor for
Ivan Tony to be included in Gareth
Southgate Squad particularly after he
scored twice for Brentford in a victory
over Manchester City last weekend 11
goals for him this season but we
discovered a few weeks ago that he was
under this fa investigation for
breaching betting rules all players are
banned from any form of football whether
directly or indirectly anywhere in the
world and this would indicate now with
the charges coming why Ivan Tony was not
selected by yagara Southgate and the
fact he'd only been called up once by
him in September and never played well
these charges relate to a four-year
period between 2017 and 2021 when he was
at Newcastle Brentford other clubs and
before joining Brent ferdy helped
Brentford gain promotions to the Premier
League for the first time and those
goals really impressing but now he's
facing potentially a ban from the game
one member of actually the England squad
came and trippier was banned himself
last year for 10 weeks for breaching
betting rules for telling a friend to
perhaps better on his transfer so these
are serious charges that Ivan Tony is
facing from the fa and they will take
some time to resolve of course the World
Cup being here in Qatar in mid-season
very unusually means the Premier League
does not resume until December the 26th
on boxing day so there is some time
before Brentford do play again and
Brentford do say they are in contact
with Tony Tony himself has only said in
recent weeks when the news first leaked
that he's in a contact assist in the fa
with their investigations meanwhile here
in Doha another day of training today
for England and Wales ahead of their
World Cup openers on Monday England
playing Iran Wales playing the United
States in their first games yeah and a
bit of a clash between the security
services and the media I believe
yeah this is not a country perhaps used
to Media roaming around the streets
freely but because there's a Fifa
tournament in town we do have the
freedom to report around in a Danish TV
crew the other night was out and about
doing a live broadcast and they were
approached by security officials
demanding to see their permits there was
a interchange on air which led to them
trying to be taken off air while
broadcasting and later the Qatari
authorities the Supreme Committee in
charge of this World Cup did Issue
fairly quick apology saying that they
should not have been disrupted in their
broadcast but what it is a reminder of
is this country is very small the local
population is only about 350
000 there's a million or so more migrant
workers but they're not used to this
sort of focus they're not used to Media
around and filming freely and it will
take challenges for the messaging to get
through to all police all security
officials to let the likes of US Reports
across the country but the Qatari
authorities certainly didn't want this
to happen from this one police officer
okay for now thank you
obviously we'll be covering that story
for you here on Sky News in more detail
meantime we're hearing that children
will face an increased risk of domestic
abuse during the World Cup according to
the National Society for the Prevention
of Cruelty to Children the nspcc the
charity said emotional stress alcohol
and betting on matches could act as
potential triggers for the incidents in
the home over the next four weeks
Homer has been named Cambridge
dictionaries word of the year after it
caused outrage among users of the hit
game Wordle back in May it's an informal
word for a home run in baseball but it's
barely known outside the US ruining many
users winning streaks when it was
wordles chosen word of the day you see I
was really irritated when they went with
mummy mummy I mean how could you
possibly guess mummy
they didn't nymph as well didn't they
didn't like nymph either now thousands
of minks are on the loose in the U.S
state of Ohio have a look
Oh I thought they were bigger than that
they're not
um the storm happened after vandals
broke into a breeding Farm destroying
fencing and cages the suspects were
thought to have released up to 40 000 of
the animals officials
um hello don't currently know if the
incident was intentional
the Met Office has issued yellow weather
warnings across the UK with forecasters
calling conditions
atrocious here we go Emergency Services
in West Sussex said 20 cars stuck in
flood water and motorists are likely to
face heavy delays
the King has sent a message of support
to Australia as widespread flooding
continues there to hit the east of the
country thousands have been evacuated in
large parts of New South Wales Victoria
and also the island of Tasmania as it
battled its fourth major flood event so
far this year
our weather here
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
it's bucketing down in London don't know
what it's doing where you are quite cool
this week and windy with widespread
showers or more prolonged rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
thought we'd look at the climate
dashboard for you given all this
appalling uh weather uh here we go 1.23
is what we are up to and that is a
global warming since 1880 this is a
real-time CO2 emissions in millions of
tons according to the University of
Oxford over here this is what our power
mix is looking like no coal again which
is good news as far as our other fossil
fuels are concerned we do have some but
Renewables more than half of what we're
doing at the moment are Renewables
things like wind of course and solar not
much solar today though especially
because it's still dark so everybody how
are you all doing this morning it's
bucketing down outside I'm afraid and is
there a storm coming with our Chancellor
budget day Jeremy Hunt will promise a
plan to weather an economic storm by
raising taxes cutting public spending
and scaling back energy support for
households when he delivers long-waited
Autumn statement it's about budget in
the comments later on this morning
around about half past 11. Charleston
Bell is director of the resolution
foundation and he is with us now hello
tutors and it's great to see you thanks
for joining us on the program what would
you expect from the budget
well good morning Kate I think we're
going to get some pretty bad economic
news for the office to budget
responsibility not just bad news on the
likes of energy bills and high inflation
but the economy growing very slowly
possibly ending this Parliament as weak
as it began it's much weaker than we
were previously expecting and actually
unemployment to rise which is the
opposite of what we've been seeing in
the recent past so pretty Grim economic
Outlook in the face of that being told
that yes you'll get some energy support
in the short term but in the longer term
it's tax Rises and spending cuts
what does that mean for many people who
are basically on the brink of not being
able to pay their mortgages
well on the tax Rises we'll probably be
largely takeaways from Midland richer
households because those are the people
that bear most of the burden of income
taxes and capital gains taxes which are
the ones that are likely to increase but
obviously reductions in public services
that those on low incomes rely on most
everyone relies on them but those are
low incomes rely on them most will be
felt most at the bottom and obviously
Rising energy bills and in particularly
look at what's happening to food prices
right now energy and food obviously key
Essentials we all need to buy they make
up a bigger basket of consumption for
lower income households and it's those
households who are seeing the highest
inflation rate right now and finding the
cost of living crisis the hardest to
deal with and what's your view on the um
Energy bill help that had been promised
by a previous Chancellor it looks as
though that is you know perhaps going to
change significantly
well we'll see what the chancellor says
later this morning but I think what
we're going to get is a combination of
the repeat of the direct payments to the
to vulnerable households pensioners
those the disability and those on Lower
incomes that Rishi sunak announced back
in May that will get repeated for
another year and then on top of that
they'll keep Liz truss's energy price
guarantee but have it for at a higher
level so allow energy bills to rise the
average Energy bill to around 3 000
pounds rather than the current 2500
level that will be for everybody
remember three thousand pounds compares
to an average Energy bill before this
crisis of around 1
000 100 pounds so these are really big
increases and then as I say targeted
help for some households those are those
that do receive that help will get you
know significant amounts maybe a
thousand pounds uh support but obviously
Lots won't including actually some of
the poorest households because remember
a four in ten of the poorest households
aren't on means-tested benefits and they
won't receive those targeted payments
what do you want them to say about
pensions I mean when we think about
pensioners we think about some that you
know are struggling and to heat their
home living in just one room and but not
all pensioners are like that
no I mean you know pensioners like
everybody have a big variety pension
inequality of income amongst pensioners
has been rising significantly in a
recent decades as a richer Boomer cohort
ages into and towards retirement so you
do have a very big diversity the good
news is that average pensioner incomes
have been growing and actually catching
up with the rest of the population over
the course of the last few decades the
typical pensioner is now about the same
income as the typical working age
household despite having lower costs but
then the bad news is because pensioners
in lots of cases are now homeowners
intend to have larger homes than younger
households these days particularly per
person their houses are actually harder
to heat they're often less energy
efficient homes too so the direct effect
of energy bills on pensioners is also
worse for them than it is for lots of
other younger populations but overall
there's been good news on the pensioner
front in recent decades talk to me about
what Andrew Bailey said yesterday
governor of the bank of England he said
the UK is in a far worse position than
the EU and the US after covid
well I mean he was specifically talking
about what's happened to our GDP the
size of our economy since the pandemic
and he's right to say that we're the
only economy in the G7 that hasn't
recovered to the size it was before the
pandemic struck and that should be a
really serious worry particularly
because it comes on the back of quite
slow growth before the pandemic remember
no business investment growth since 2016
and low wage growth even going back
until the financial crisis remember we
went into the pandemic with the same
level of wages we had going into the
financial crisis so this really has been
a terrible 15 years almost of economic
performance for the country some bright
spots like on employment but overall on
GDP on productivity on our wages it's
been a disaster
okay great to see you thanks for
checking the time thanks
see ya
Dominic Robb says he's confident that he
has behaved professionally while Deputy
Prime Minister despite him facing an
investigation into claims he bullied
members of his team
I received notification this morning I
immediately asked the Prime Minister set
up an independent uh inquiry into them
I'm confident I pay professionally
throughout but of course I will engage
thoroughly and look forward Mr Speaker
may I say look forward to transparently
addressing any claims that have been
made
this Carly is a former government
advisor and he is with us now hi Alex
good to see you
um what is the right thing to do under
these circumstances
and the right thing to do is exactly
what dominic Robb has done as soon as a
formal complaint was made and of course
in the run-up to yesterday all we had
was uh rumors and gossip and Anonymous
briefings to newspapers as soon as that
entered the system as it were he's done
exactly the right thing and referred
himself to an independent investigation
to establish what the claims actually
are and whether they have any Merit
so how is this different to what
happened with
um sir Gavin Williamson who you know he
he was in a similar position and then he
resigned a couple of days later
where it was slightly different in that
with with Gavin Williamson it wasn't
entirely a civil service matter it was
more a matter of uh between him and
other parliamentary colleagues and of
course with Gavin Williamson we did uh
unfortunately have a much greater
understanding of what the claims
actually were and people were able to
make a judgment and crucially of course
Rishi sunak as PM was able to make an
informed judgment about that and then
clearly Gavin Williamson walked before
before he was probably inevitably pushed
with Dominic Robb all we've got is is a
sort of vague uh sense that that he
might have said something uh to someone
but that we don't actually have any
details
um well we don't know what the details
are but of course the uh complaint has
been made now so somebody will
um Davey Davis
um telling me I'm sure you've worked
with him and your time in government
that Mr Rob is a tough character but not
a bully what do you think
it's a fair assessment I think if you
talk to anyone who has worked uh with
him directly or or or with people who
have worked with him they will tell you
the same thing uh yes he is robust uh
yes he is direct
um does that amount to bullying uh I
don't personally think so I don't know
what these specific allegations are
um but I don't I don't necessarily think
it's a bad thing to have a minister who
wants to drive delivery and who wants to
do so in a very direct manner um that
that that General attitude is probably
something we could do a little bit more
of
so has the attitude in your opinion
changed um in Westminster
um over the last few years
the attitude towards the wall sorry to
the attitude towards dealing with
members of staff and also colleagues
well I don't I I don't know I think you
get you get different characters uh in
politics some of them are very very
direct others are are more passive each
each Minister each MP has their own
style
um Luke Westminster is or can be a very
tricky place to work because the
pressures are huge and also the stakes
are huge you you know particularly in
ministerial office you're dealing with
very very big decisions that that really
really impact people's lives we you
spoke just now about the economic impact
on lower income families of of the
forthcoming budget these are the stakes
so yes you're going to have situations
um where people are going to be very
direct with each other
how would you describe Boris
uh how long you got
um
he the the thing I can say about him uh
succinctly is that he is he is not a
manager a manager I don't think anyone
ever claimed he was
um he is someone that his method of
driving delivery is he he wants he he
wants people to impress him he because
he has that sort of Stardust about him
that the people who work for and around
him they want his approval and therefore
they they extend themselves and they
think that if they do a really good job
they'll get a bit of that kind of Boris
charm and approval coming their way
um that that's his style and of course
other politicians have have other
different styles as well but it's he
wants to give something he wants to give
people something to live up to
could he his um approach uh be described
as direct and some might want to
interpret that as bullying
I don't think so um I I think he's so he
he certainly tells you what he thinks uh
you know if you you know if you give him
an idea that that is weak or an idea
that he doesn't agree with he you know
he he is going to challenge that but
that's absolutely right
um the last thing you want is as a
political leader to to sit there and
sort of not along and not really offer
an opinion that that doesn't really move
things forward I certainly wouldn't
characterize anything it's certainly in
my experience I wouldn't characterize
boris's style in that way at all and of
course famously he didn't he doesn't
really like confrontation so
um you know again it's a very different
style okay it's good to talk to you
thanks for the Insight much appreciated
thank you Tamara is at Downing Street
for us this morning uh waiting to hear
from the chancellor around about 11 30
or thereabouts
um Tamara I don't think the chancellor
could ever be described
um as bullying or direct
well Jeremy Hunt will stand up at the
dispatch box today and say that we need
to face into the storm and it's the
right weather for that here in Downing
Street today he'll say there are
difficult decisions to be made tax Rises
and spending cuts over the coming years
in order to tackle what he says is the
key enemy and that is inflation which is
eroding people's wages eroding people's
savings and making everything that we
need Essentials for day-to-day life more
expensive so what we can be expecting to
set out today well a lot of it we know
in advance because one of the key issues
for the chancellor and the Prime
Minister who touched down from Bali this
morning is that they didn't want any big
surprises like Liz truss and
quasiquarting they wanted people to be
prepared for it so we can expect what we
can call stealth tax Rises so people who
aren't currently paying a 20p or 40p or
45p rates of tax to be dragged into them
over the coming years to be paying a
little bit more ever every year and for
it for the next five years or so so the
government can try and make up some of
this shortfall we also expect some very
difficult decisions on spending cuts
around 30 billion pounds of spending
cuts will be announced today not all of
them to happen immediately we expect
some level of protection for the NHS but
other departments whether it's schools
local councils the justice system are
going to after already a decade of
austerity have to make more difficult
decisions some conservative MPS are a
bit nervy about all of this particularly
the tax Rises given the pain people are
already facing on their energy bills
over the coming months and years and how
this lands whether it actually works in
salvaging the economic picture is really
crucial to whether the conservatives can
recover in the polls the Prime Minister
knows that the decision he makes today
are going to be crucial to his future
okay lovely thank you alongside his
statement Jeremy Hunt will also publish
the findings of independent economic
forecasts it's those gloomy predictions
that are driving many of The Swinging
spending cuts and tax Rises that he'll
be laying out our data and economics
editor Ed Conway looks at the scale of
the challenge facing a chancellor
what can we look out for well first of
all there's the state of the economy the
update we get from the office for Budget
responsibility on how we're doing and
starting with gross domestic product
these numbers are likely the higher they
are the faster we're growing they're
likely to be revised down of course
given the UK is facing a recession at
the moment and when it comes to
inflation obviously we just had those
latest data on inflation those bars
might well go up it's just underlining
what we're facing here in the country as
is this this is a chart that they showed
last time around back in March and it's
pretty striking the higher these bars
are the better we're doing the bigger
our household disposable income increase
each year you can see most years it's
going up so anything above the line but
last time around look at what happened
to their forecast look at that bar there
down at the lowest level the biggest
fall we've seen on record and the big
question now is will that get worse
we'll have to wait and see but it's not
just about those numbers about the
economy about our pockets it's also
about the public finances and about talk
of a black hole what do we mean by black
hole well it comes back to this this is
the national all debt okay and this is
what was expected last time around for
it to be gradually falling but then of
course came the midi budget and look at
this rather than falling it started to
rise those are those kind of
unsustainable uh increases in the public
finances in the national debt that
caused equality introduced and what's
the black hole is basically about
eliminating all of that getting it down
so it's falling again over the next five
years and that could well cost 50 60
billion pounds according to the
government so we'll have to wait and see
precisely what that means does it mean a
new era of austerity and on top of that
of course we will be watching out for
things like this bond yields what's
happening in the market reaction of
course last time around that was the big
story will it be this time we'll have to
wait and see
uh not too long to wait now though half
past 11 thereabouts we're going to be
hearing from the chance when he gets to
his feet in House of Commons what will
the lube Dems make of it Sarah only
treasury spokesperson for the lib Dems
is with us good morning good morning
thanks for joining us uh what do you
want to hear
well I think there's several very
important things we want to hear we want
to hear that pensions and benefits are
going to be upgraded in line with
inflation we think that's essential to
protect the poorest from the worst
impact of the of the cost of living
crisis we want to see health and
education budgets increased in real
terms and the real terms is really
important because we know from yesterday
that inflation has gone up now to 11.1
percent which is one of the highest
rates on record so it's really really
important that we continue to uh to
manage our waiting lists in the
healthcare sector and also to make sure
that we are protecting our young people
and our children and supporting their
learning but I think what's really
disappointing what's really dismaying
and I think what a lot of your viewers
will be really unhappy about is that
every single person in this country
every single taxpayer is going to see an
increase in their taxes to pay for this
government's atrocious mishandling of
the economy we know from the resolution
foundation for example that 10 billion
pounds worth of extra borrowing costs is
as a direct result of the interest rate
hike we saw as a result of the mini
budget in September and so this black
hole which is really a blue hole it's
it's a creation of this Tory government
and that's what the tax increases are
going to have to pay for it's a cost to
Everyday taxpayers of the conservatives
mishandling of the economy yeah but now
it's those who can most afford to pay it
that are going to be expected to pay
very different to what we saw in
September I don't think that's true I
think absolutely everybody is going to
find their taxes increased with what
we're hearing is a freezing of the
personal allowance and a freezing of
thresholds and we know that most workers
are going to receive somewhere between a
five and eight percent increase in their
pay this year and of course that's below
inflation so it's a cut in real terms
but for many people that will be enough
to pull them into either paying tax for
the first time or pull them into that
higher 40 tax rate band so not only are
they getting a a pay cut in real terms
they are also so paying more of their
take-home pay in in in tax yeah but if
you want um the triple lock to stay in
place if you want
um 10 or 11 Zone in line with inflation
Rises for those uh that need credits
from the government if you want the NHS
to be ring fenced and get more money if
you want more money for the Department
of Department of Education where is it
going to come from unless it's from more
taxes well the liberal Democrats have
been calling for over a year for a
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
well but we were calling for it back in
October last year and if it had been
levied at that time we we estimate we
could have raised 60 billion over three
years to pay for public services
we've got a different chance oh we've
had four different chancellors I've only
been the treasury spokesperson since
July and there have been four different
chancellors since then and you know this
this constant changing of faces at
number 10 and number 11 is fueling some
of the political instability which is
making the uh the financial market so uh
to react over looking at the power and
it's a dollar nineteen I mean it was a
dollar three uh not too long ago this
Chancellor seems to be making a
difference no well it's partly an in
anticipation of what he's going to say
today but I think what I was saying is
the liberal Democrats would have uh
would have imposed a windfall tax who
would have done it much earlier we would
have done it on the excess profits that
the oil and gas companies uh I have been
making as a result of wholesale gas
prices going up as a direct result of
Putin's illegal invasion of Ukraine
um and what we saw when the government
finally adopted our suggestion uh and
and implemented a windfall tax is that
they've created an offset they've
allowed oil in and gas companies to
offset their investment in in more oil
and gas drilling so shell we know
reported a few weeks ago billions of
pounds worth of profit and not a single
penny paid in Windfall tax and that's
just part of this government's
incompetence and you know the liberal
Democrats have been making lots of
policy suggestions over the last year
the windfall tax we were the first to
propose that and we were the first to
propose an energy price guarantee for
households and businesses okay you're
suggesting uh that households could face
an increase of nearly five thousand
pounds a year after the statement tell
us where you get where you get that
figure from well it's a combination of
all the different price Rises so of
course there's the uh there's the fuel
increase which even with the energy
price guarantee most households are
going to see quite a a substantial
increase in their fuel prices there's
the food bills that are going up and the
underlying inflation on food we saw
yesterday outstrips the headline
inflation figure then of course there's
interest rates on mortgages and then of
course there's the extra taxes so all in
all that adds up to a massive uh extra
uh watch of cost as it were for the
average household many of whom as I say
will not be getting real terms pay
increases this year which is about 100
pounds a week is what you'll say it's
going to cost more I think so and I
think many families are already seeing
that and there's extra taxes that we
think the uh Chancellor is going to
announce today will be extremely
difficult for many to manage and that
will see a big hit to household incomes
do you have anything positive to say
about this Chancellor
um well probably he's better than the
last one but really that's quite a low
bar so
we're exciting about half past 11 there
um it'd be great to hear what you think
about it once we've heard from the
chancellor thank you very much thank you